you see I didn't understand that at all
I don't think I don't particularly does
the Father Son Holy Spirit the Holy
Ghost
what about Jesus dying for your sins
didn't make any sense either for any man
to do as he pleases and still still go
to the afterlife or how does our patient
leave out all the long one guy one God
one God Jesus is a messenger for Allah
makes the messenger so walking through
the streets of Manchester very cloudy
rains a lot Manchester and we found this
M why what's that let's check it out
UK father get the nice calligraphy on
the wall very nice
cupping get with it The Lost Sunnah
let's revive that anybody knows about it
and know the power of it and every time
you do it some active you bother you're
gonna get rewarded for it my F
we're here with John Paul I'll sit for
me in with the spoke I don't get
beautiful so what had you reflecting on
the purpose of life to really take that
step before you got into making the
decision to practice the decision life
was going to church all the way through
my childhood eventually going to church
every Saturday every Sunday with my
children and also get the answers that I
was looking for through Christianity so
the fact he said that Jesus is God the
see I've got heard the church the
priests I didn't feel like that
particularly that well learnt I didn't
feel like they were coming with a true
message of ISA a Salaam so eventually I
want to go to see the Jews at the
synagogue they said you know you can't
join us but you can live like us I
fought there's only one place left to go
to so you went to the finish I went to
the synagogue you can't join us yeah
more or less more or less they said you
have to be born at you tomorrow because
I started reading the Old Testament yeah
obviously you were really hungry to want
to know very hungry very hungry I
started it I just picked up Genesis you
know the Pentateuch the first five books
of Moses started reading that and for I
want to live this way quit the alcohol
quit the pork pray to God all right I'll
do you hold order I've stayed three it's
only two years ago okay so you went
through all the things in life
experience and their stuff just gets
played out yeah definitely so now you're
really you want to know the purpose you
want it you believe in a creator of
course okay you want to know the path
that he's sent for you to be a part one
hundred percent on your son so luckily
all the guy did make like say I could go
into Church has two priests the
questions they did get with the answers
what kind of questions were you asking
the priest missing chapters from the
Bible the Gospel of Thomas Gospel of
Barnabas the Gospel of Enoch
you know the grandfather in nowhere I
wasn't getting answers I was looking for
yeah and I didn't feel satisfied Mike
didn't fulfill my hunger the church what
about Trinity well Tracy I did not
understand that at all I don't think I
don't particularly does the Father Son
Holy Spirit the Holy Ghost
what about Jesus dying for your sins
didn't make any sense either about any
money to do as he pleases and still
still goes to the afterlife or Paul does
not make sense yeah so now you compare
that with Islam so now you're you go to
the synagogue you go all these religions
now what is it about Islam many people
don't understand people go around the
world every religion but now when they
come to Islam yes
it's like you know you got these you
know
for example yes easy to go ahead if you
really are sincere and you want to know
and there's let's say the fake watches
on fake goals right of course put it to
the test it's gonna turn green your
body's gonna turn green when you finally
test this long yes yes you know this is
from the Creator
so what happened now what's happening
now but you you what is it tell us the
story from there the story from there
been to synagogue couldn't become Jewish
thought fair enough go to the Masjid I
kept driving all the a6 towards
Manchester I kept seeing quite a lot of
masters - quite a lot of moss something
just maybe wanna go inside of one and
ask questions so I came here two years
ago and met Akram I also met a brother
called Mohammed and they told me all
about it
he said there's a crater has a purpose
for you everything's made with intent
studies one and I believe that all along
one God one God one God Jesus is a
messenger for what makes he's a
messenger for example it says in the
Bible that Jesus is a prophet he's a
teacher he's a preacher he's a Nabi they
called him a rabbi it was simple yeah
yeah it was all clarified okay so now
you look at the evidence as Salaam
provides all the evidence Islam means
submission to the will of God is the way
of life Jesus Jesus was awesome he
submitted son Salaam submission to the
will of God basic easy to understand one
God
yes three and one three and four yes now
what's the step finally become a Muslim
you testify what's in your nature
well the Shahada that what happened
there what happened they gave me the
crown I took the homeowner holidays
whales for my family
day by day at breakfast time on their
most grumbled eggs on my toast reading
through the Quran and I thought this is
for me so four months later I converted
to Islam and what did you do what did
you do what did you have to do what was
the step the steps was the Shahada which
I said in English at home and then I
come to a Masjid and said it in Arabic
in this very room just all there at the
right from foot of about 30 brothers and
that's pretty simple you testified that
there's nothing worthier worse yes yes
it's first it's a negation yes nothing
worthy of worship no deity where they
worship except the crater the has honor
yes the same God that Jesus worship
Abraham Moses what's your relationship
with Jesus now better than ever before I
love you more than ever before
excuse my simple you might be shocked to
hear that but it's the truth yes yes
yeah certainly so that is a God or
literal son of God but as a message
like Moses Abraham Noah funnel mister
problem how many peas opposed to be upon
him and the challenges obviously God
Almighty tells us this you you think
you're just gonna say I believe you're
not gonna be tested how have you dealt
with these tests of corn of course they
call it says just cuz you convert to
Islam doesn't mean we're gonna not test
you you know you don't get off scot-free
testicle my way trials and tribulations
my patience has been a lot better when I
can stay grounded I can stay calm I can
wait
Vence or better and I know that he loses
more the more you testers more our
losses that's why he does it if I make
sense so you heard about the deal yes of
course a hug yes I started watching it
before I converted to Islam and I just
read in the Quran I was watching your
videos John Fontaine's videos done
sasaki like everyone contain everyone's
videos what do you what do you have to
say for those people who are full of
misinformation about Islam and
misinformation and they stereotypes they
got some apprehension yes but they like
this idea of worship and only one guy
what advice do I have I was full of
almost anger towards Islam I thought why
these guys terrorists who was Muhammad
barbaric I thought I've got questions
like debating people so thought I'm
gonna have to go and debate with them
and ask them myself
and they gave me all the clear answers
and all those preconceptions were just
pushed alongside I knew the first time I
come in here within 10 minutes I was
already a Muslim Wow not quickly for me
that's deep we love sharing these kind
of stories to help motivate people to
seek purpose to want to know where'd you
come from why are you here where are you
going when you die some answers all of
that with our brother yes I'm Colin nice
to meet you brother
yeah your brother somebody cool